we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors blinkist is the app that helps
you become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman steady md lets you maintain
a meaningful long lasting relationship
with a primary care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit
steadymd.com pacman to get started
i have good news and bad news to start
with today
and they're both the same depending on
your perspective
donald trump last night gave what is
likely to be his last rally ever
as president of the united states if you
like the trump craziness it's coming to
an end
if you dislike it it's coming to an end
so it's good or bad depending on your
perspective
it was bizarre it was deranged it was
also really boring
and it took place in georgia the point
of the rally
supposedly was to support the two
republican senators running in today's
elections kelly leffler and david perdue
but down to every detail the entire
event was
a farce david perdue couldn't even be at
the rally
because he's in coronavirus quarantine
of the nearly 90 minutes that donald
trump ranted
almost none of it was about the senate
candidates it was mostly
about trump much of it telling lie after
lie
it is not an exaggeration to say donald
trump told hundreds of lies during
yesterday's rally insisting he won
at one point simply citing supposed
county level vote count numbers from
election night the crowd completely
silent for long stretches of the rally
and down to the last element i mean even
trump's face
more orange than we've ever seen it
despite his pale hands
every detail could not have been more
absurd and as i like to say
indistinguishable from satire
so let's get right into it here is
donald trump within seconds opening up
the rally by lying about the results in
georgia
well i want to thank you very much hello
georgia by the way
there's no way we lost georgia there's
no way
the rig that was a rigged election
but we're still fighting it and you'll
see what's going to happen we'll talk
about it and
and this was the theme trump moments
later
saying if democrats take the white house
and then realizing hold on a second no
no no
they're not taking it we won if the
liberal democrats take the senate or the
white house
and they're not taking this white house
we're going to fight like hell i'll tell
you right now
and the theme was that the crowd really
didn't seem to care very much
about lefleur and perdue they seemed to
just be there for trump but even
trump got too boring for them for long
stretches and they tuned
out which we'll get to donald trump then
alluding to once again
hoping that mike pence can steal
the election for him tomorrow and i hope
mike pence comes through for us i have
to tell you
i hope that our great vice president
our great vice president comes through
for us he's a great guy
of course if he doesn't come through i
won't like him quite as much
so this is wild for two reasons first
that donald trump is publicly pressuring
the vice president
to steal the election and second that
donald trump
seems to believe that mike pence can
steal the election pence's role in
washington dc tomorrow as we talked
about yesterday
is really perfunctory and we're all
going to see that tomorrow so i won't
get get ahead of myself
here is an example of donald trump
ranting about things nobody in the crowd
seemed to understand and the crowd is
silent at one point i wondered
did the crowd leave but they were there
just not making a peep
and you've got to swarm it tomorrow now
the good thing about tomorrow
it's one state so you have a lot of
eyeballs watching it's tougher
than when you have 50 states and they do
it to
various various states i'd never say
they like it
you know i was leading in pennsylvania
by
hundreds of thousands of votes all of a
sudden i was tired i said what happened
they'll make washington dc and other
liberal places
the 51st 52nd 53rd
states of the union guaranteeing you can
almost hear the room tone
louder than you can hear the crowd it's
it's really wild how
dead silent trump was able to get this
crowd to be
trump then defiantly clarifying he does
not concede
even though he did lose two months ago
after all nothing and no one will be
able to stop them
the senate seats are truly the
last line of defense now i must preface
that by saying because they'll say he
just conceded
no no i don't think so
that got the crowd awake trump not
conceding that's the one thing he should
be doing and mentioning that is what
really gets the crowd fired up
so then this is funny when donald trump
did talk about david perdue and kelly
lefler which was almost not at all
but that was the point of the rally in
theory the crowd is totally bored when
trump talks about purdue and leffler
here he is talking about david perdue
who it wasn't even clear whether trump
knew purdue wasn't there because he was
quarantining
doesn't matter you'll see the camera if
you're watching pan around and although
the
lack of masks is notable the lack of
enthusiasm is as well
over the last four years david perdue
has been one of our greatest allies and
strongest offenders in washington he's a
great gentleman and then the crowd just
as bored
when trump was talking about kelly
lefler just barely a cheer
georgia has another fantastic champion
in senator kelly lefler kelly is a
staunch defender of our
incredible military i'm so proud of our
military she supports the wall
and she always stands with the heroes of
law enforcement ice
usually they pump up the crowd noise i
was wondering whether they were
suppressing the crowd noise and that's a
joke
they weren't the crowd was just that
silent for much of this rally a deflated
empty speech the cringiest moment
in the whole thing was probably this
moment when donald trump called up
republican senate candidate kelly lefler
to the stage
and she had an announcement to make
which was that tomorrow
she will object object to the counting
of the electoral votes that got the
crowd uh interested they woke up for
that
hello georgia
thank you georgia i have an announcement
georgia
on january 6th i will object to the
electoral college vote
that's right that's right
thank you what energy right i mean just
the the energy just oozing off of kelly
lefler there
loudly announcing she will also be
making a fool out of herself in
washington dc tomorrow
and trump then seemed to be visibly
struggling
to get to the end of his speech you're
going to hear him sort of
slurring here mixing up words the last
20 minutes were just
one of the most uh uh poorly delivered
speeches
that i've seen from trump and that says
a lot we have all seen
what our opponents are capable of doing
i ran two elections i won both of them
second one much more successful than the
first
but we can't let this happen any longer
on election night
we were leading by so much we're not
going to have that tomorrow
so then this is the part that's really
nuts
for about 20 straight minutes
trump read with terrible inflection and
tone
alleged voting results from various
counties and here he is wanting to talk
about
maricopa county arizona but he's only
only able to get out the word maya copa
and it doesn't even matter because
everybody's tuned out by this point
anyway
it's his constituents reported that
their
earlier in-person ballots may not have
been correctly processed or tabulated
myacopa county officials yeah so this
was the part that
had the crowd completely checked out
just droning on like this for 20 minutes
here's another part of it
you could really hear a pin drop in this
place the committee then heard
additional testimony concerning voting
irregularities during the 2020 general
election
including testimony and a real-time test
demonstrating serious irregularities
with dominions voting machines
three events discussed at this hearing
stand out and require a forensic order
of the dominion
voting machines in georgia to be
immediately conducted
the one phrase that woke people back up
was trump
mentioning dominion voting machines the
sycophants have almost been trained in a
pavlovian manner
if you hear dominion that you have to
react to but they were really struggling
to remain even remotely engaged with
trump droning on and on about votes and
ballots
and then during his wind-up sort of
crescendo
uh trump actually glitches on the word
america
and he tries to cover it up by flexing
his bicep
we have made strong again look at that
arm
trump commonly does this we saw this
dozens and dozens of times during his
presidency when he
sort of glitches out during a word he'll
do something physical to distract from
it he'll flex his arm or he'll slap the
lectern a couple of times or he'll turn
to the other side of the audience and
say whoa hey how about that
so trump's final rally as expected
all about himself he seemed sort of to
try to go through the motions of talking
about david perdue and kelly lefler
but he really couldn't do it and what he
did do is spend a lot of time claiming
that he won in november
we are very close to the end very very
close
and the next question is what will trump
do
between tomorrow when the electoral
votes are counted
and january 20th when joe biden is sworn
in will we see him at all
will he tweet will he go crazy tweeting
will he not tweet
at all we don't know but you can join me
tonight
live on youtube twitch and facebook for
georgia
senate results starting somewhere in the
7 pm eastern hour
and then tomorrow at 1 pm eastern join
me live on youtube twitch and facebook
for the counting of the electoral votes
supposedly
the last stand for the trumpists
tomorrow 1 pm eastern
join me tonight and join me tomorrow all
right this is super interesting and it's
really just a pleasure to watch
one of the most prominent people who
plans to formally object
sir i object to the counting of the
electoral votes tomorrow
is republican senator josh hawley
because josh hawley was
i guess because he was the first senator
to announce he would object
he's received more attention than some
other senators who jumped on the
bandwagon after the fact
and josh hawley went on fox news
yesterday good for him
and brett bayer actually pushed back on
the nonsense that josh hawley was
touting and josh hawley
became visibly uncomfortable he had that
look on his face that tucker carlson is
known for
where it's sort of like a dog hearing
your voice out of the answering machine
and kind of like a confusion um and when
bret bayer starts pushing back on josh
hawley josh hawley gets that look
here is bret bayer starting with what
exactly is the point of you objecting
tomorrow or you know wednesday uh what
what do you what is the goal of that
take a listen
so the supreme court didn't take up that
that case either they did not take up
the quick case the
the supreme court we've seen courts
across the country
deal not only with not the standing of
different cases but
also the evidence and some of them
trump's trump judges i just want to
pin you down on on what you're trying to
do you know
are you trying to say that as of january
20th
that president trump will be president
well that that depends on what happens
on wednesday i mean this is why we have
the debate
no it doesn't i mean the states by the
constitution
say they certify the election they did
certify it
by the constitution congress doesn't
have the right to overturn the
certification
at least as most experts read it so
brett bayer is completely correct
tomorrow's electoral vote count is
ceremonial
mike pence's role is perfunctory the
states have already certified their
electoral votes that's the legally
binding piece state certification
tomorrow is really ceremonial
and this is where josh hawley starts to
get a sourpuss
look on his face like he bit into a
lemon and just
start to tell some lies well congress is
is directed under the 12th amendment to
count the electoral votes there's a
statute that dates back to the
19 to the 1800s rather 19th century that
says that there is a right to object
there's a right to be heard and there's
also certification right that's from
1876 senator and it's it's the
the tilden hayes race in which there
were three states that did not certify
their
their electors so congress was left to
come up with this system this commission
that eventually got to a negotiated
grand bargain but
now all of the states have certified
their elections
as of december 14th so it doesn't by
constitutional ways
open a door to congress to overturn that
does it when brett
bayer knows the example that holly is
referring to
holly realizes oh no this is not going
to go that well
and brett bayer is completely correct
what josh hawley
is referring to is a mechanism that's
really in place for when
some states have not certified the
electoral vote
that's not the case this year every
state on
uh what december 14th can you believe
it's been a month since then it feels
like days
on december 14th every state certified
the electoral vote
and then listen to josh hawley's answer
well no i'm talking about the statute
brett there's a statute that says that
governs what congress does
on january the 6th and it says
that we have a vote of certification and
that we have to we have the opportunity
to debate the results to certify the
results we count them and then we
certify
and my point is this is my only
opportunity
during this process to raise an
objection and to be heard i don't have
standing to file lawsuits
i'm not a prosecutor anymore i used to
be but i'm not anymore i can't
investigate
claims of voter fraud on my own but i do
have a responsibility
in this joint session of congress to
either say i've got no problem with it
or i do have a problem with it and my
constituents expect
their responsibility to your
constituents don't you have a
responsibility to tell them that it's
not going to be
president trump as of january 21st as
well
well bret so there josh hawley kind of
admits the truth
which is this is all i can do and that's
what this is all about
what is there that anyone can do given
that joe biden won
and all they can do is virtue signal to
donald trump
that they are trying that they are
trying so holly has definitely
uh he he seemed to be expecting more of
a fawning softball interview from bret
bayer
much of the fox news audience is furious
with bret bayer for pointing out that
josh hawley
is lying to them after all you would
think that an audience would want to
know
if an elected official is lying to them
but no
the fox audience is mad that bret bayer
exposed josh hawley's lies but holly's
just squirming and it's fantastic
and it will all be over very soon i'm
still receiving
and we even got some paid super chats
during yesterday's trump rally
live stream i'm still getting messages
from people saying
totally seriously david don't you
realize that by thursday
trump will be the official winner and
biden is going to be in handcuffs
well listen i don't even have to argue
we're down to the last 48 hours
let's wait and see and we will see very
soon let me know what you expect
tomorrow in washington dc
uh let me know via twitter where you can
find me at d pacman
the david pakman show at david
davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so this is just magical yesterday
as we already discussed donald trump did
what might be his last ever
rally as president and he did it in
dalton georgia
and fox news channel was on the ground
there and reporter griff jenkins was
interviewing people and he starts
interviewing some guy with a huge red
stop of the steel hat who apparently had
been camping out
in a sleeping bag awaiting last night's
rally and as this is going on there's a
guy in a maga hat in the background
flashing this new white power hand
signal with his hand
and i'll explain more about that in a
moment um and although it takes about 12
seconds too long maybe 14 seconds
eventually
fox news makes the decision to just cut
the video and
they cut to a shot of the white house in
which nothing is going on
and i'll explain to you after we look at
the clip how we know that this was
definitely an abrupt decision made live
they weren't
purposely saying hey at this point we
planned
to show you what was going on at the
white house it was a decision made on
the fly to get the white power symbol
off the screen
take a look and then we'll discuss and
the elections tomorrow do you care about
that are you worried about that
absolutely i think everybody in the
nation should care about it it's a
federal
issue in a way who becomes senators it's
going to have a very big impact on the
senate
i support senators purdue and lafleur i
hope that they are elected
um and you know if somebody from
california can come out here
and camp out in zero degree weather in a
sleeping bag on the asphalt
maybe a few more voters from georgia
will find the time to get to the polls
and quickly blake do you believe since
you're worried about the stop to steal
in election uh shenanigans are you
worried about the integrity of the
election tomorrow for lefleur and purdue
yeah absolutely i'm worried about it i
just hope that the correct actions have
been taken to make sure that this time
around
the ballot custody is safeguarded and
there aren't you know extra
so after about 14 seconds of that white
power sign being held up
they switched to a shot of the white
house now we can tell this was a sort of
emergency measure
an abrupt evasive maneuver because
number one nothing is happening at the
white house in the shot
number two they keep the white house
video
up too long to make any visual sense and
number three if it was on purpose
when news networks switch to a shot of
the white house
either the voice over or a lower third
will tell you why we are looking at the
white house like for example
they'd switch to a shot of the white
house and they would say at the bottom
awaiting
trump departure from white house or
something along those lines
so clearly this was like an abrupt uh
attempt
to cover the white power hand signal
that was taking place
during the interview now hilariously the
12 or 14 seconds
it took to put the sh to pull the shot
off of the screen
i would love to know what the
conversation was in the control room oh
no
white power sign do do we cut it no no
no that's too abrupt let's just wait and
hope the guy takes it down
oh no he's keeping it up okay let's cut
it yeah but what do we cut to
i don't know maybe the white house yeah
yeah yeah cut to the white house real
quick
now just to do this justice and make it
informative
you might be saying white power symbol
the the okay hand sign
ever since i was a kid that didn't mean
white power how does it
now mean white power and context is key
here we have to be able to
as as intelligent homo sapiens apply
an understanding of context in most
situations the okay
hand sign is perfectly fine and
it would be obvious to everybody that it
means okay not
white power the idea of the hand sign
is that it creates a w and a p
and we're putting up a drawing of that
on the screen and this dates back to a
2017
hoax from the internet where it was
falsely promoted
as a symbol of hate so understand and a
lot of people
if you don't mention this they get mad
the origins were
for an online enclave to pretend
that this is a symbol of hate meaning
white power and that it's not
in reality but then by 2019 it actually
lost some of the satire and there are
people who now
seriously use it as a symbol of hate and
the point is
we shouldn't jump to conclusions we have
to analyze each situation
here we have someone who's deliberately
standing in the background
of a shot at a political rally holding
the sign up while wearing trump gear
context
tells us he's not telling us everything
is okay and the weather is great
all right so whether in this case it's a
satirical white power signal
or a real white power signal clearly
this guy is not saying
great weather guys that's what i'm
communicating and even fox news
recognized it eventually i mean it took
them 12 or 14 seconds
uh and they cut away what an amazing
time we live in isn't it
let's do a little bit of a um i don't
know
talking sense on vaccination because the
vaccination
disinformation that is spreading is
absolutely ridiculous now i want to be
very clear
this is not a segment to correct medical
misinformation about vaccines
later today we'll talk to dr eric topple
about the medical aspects of vaccination
we've done that before uh so so this is
not about
oh the vaccine will give you covet or
bill gates will micro trip you
we've debunked that stuff separately
this is a segment about
the political misinformation about
coronavirus vaccines things like
trump delivered a vaccine or
operation warp speed is doing great
thanks to america for the vaccine that
type of stuff
so this is going to be a great
opportunity to go over where we are
today on vaccination and the bottom line
is the first vaccine to be approved
the pfizer biontech vaccine was
developed
by two turkish immigrants to germany in
germany
very early in the pandemic before donald
trump did a thing about
the coronavirus it had nothing to do
with trump it had nothing to do with the
trump administration
period donald trump has bragged about
how thanks to him
we developed vaccines faster than ever
before that has
nothing to do with donald trump the
reason we developed vaccines so quickly
is that the mrna platform for vaccines
instead of working on dead or weakened
virus
works by giving cells instructions for
how to make
proteins that trigger an immune response
that technology by its nature shortens
the vaccine development time that's why
the vaccines both in and out of the us
were developed so quickly has nothing to
do with donald trump
uh so so in terms of development there's
very little to even talk about
regarding donald trump now what does
have to do with donald trump
is vaccine distribution in the united
states and that's been an absolute and
total disaster
number one remember that donald trump
previously promised us 100 million
vaccine doses by the end of the year
last year 2020 we didn't get there
more recently the trump administration
promised 20 million
vaccinations by the end of 2020. we did
not get there
and where we are today and bloomberg has
a very good vaccine tracker
is that as of a few hours ago 13 million
doses of the vaccine have been
distributed and that term were still
unclear on on
distributed means what exactly only
4 million 4.3 million first doses have
been
injected and remember that you need two
doses
um with the current vaccines the second
doses are just now
starting so we were supposedly going to
have 20 million vaccinated by december
31st
instead we have 4.3 million partially
vaccinated
by january 5th this is an abject failure
now it's not completely clear what the
hold up is
but this is going very much like testing
they lied about testing early
and they seem to be lying about vaccines
early as well
so for things that actually have to do
with trump which are
vaccination distribution it's a disaster
there is one other aspect to this
vaccination is going to remain
slower than it has to be thanks to
donald trump
as i told you last the week before last
in late july trump turned down the
opportunity to buy another 100 million
doses from pfizer
so pfizer said okay well if you don't
want them we'll sell them to other
countries and that's exactly what they
did
so instead of getting another 100
million doses
in the first quarter of this year or
even in the second quarter of this year
donald trump has now salvaged a purchase
of 100 million more pfizer doses
from a future shipment which are due to
us by july
31. we don't get those until july 31
that means that those will not be
injected into people
until august september and october
utterly embarrassing and a total failure
that's the real record
of the trump administration on vaccines
great things have
happened including the development of
multiple effective vaccines
uh and and the start of a vaccination
program none of that has to do with
trump where trump was involved which is
this early logistics program
it's been a failure it would be
hilarious
except it is an utter tragedy of
cataclysmic proportions
which is leading to unnecessary death
hopefully
president joe biden will be able to
accelerate vaccine distribution
we'll have more about this on the david
pakman show
instagram page find us there at david
pakman show
you can find me on instagram as well at
david.pakman
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into a doctor's office right now
and thankfully there's a practical and
affordable way
to take control of your health and get
personalized
care from the comfort of your home it's
a service called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays i took their
quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me is a really
perfect fit for me
and my medical needs they have a special
offer only for my audience you'll get 50
off your first month but only until
january 31st so make sure to sign up
soon
click the link right underneath this
video
welcome back to the david pakman show
today i'm going to be speaking with dr
eric topel who is
founder and director of the scripps
research translational institute
also a professor of molecular medicine
and
executive vice president at scripps
research it's so great to have you on i
really appreciate it
oh david great to be with you so let's
let's maybe
start with vaccination and and kind of
center our conversation there
um we have currently uh two
approved vaccines in the united states
under emergency use
authorization for coronavirus the pfizer
biontech vaccine
as well as the moderna vaccine there are
other vaccines that have started to be
approved in other
countries all currently correct me if
i'm wrong
mrna platform vaccines
there has been much made of the short
amount of time
it has taken to get these vaccines this
is something that is merely a function
of the platform is that right
it just takes less time to develop a
vaccine under this paradigm
well a few things just to clear up there
so yes
the mrna platform did work very quickly
within days
of having the sequence of the virus that
was released
from the chinese scientist in january
within days there was already a template
for an mrna vaccine but there are some
other vaccines besides the two that you
mentioned
that have gotten approval on an
emergency basis in other countries
but they're not mrna so for example the
astrazeneca is an adenovirus vector
not an mrna um basically
and a couple of the chinese firm uh and
the russian
sputnik these are different they they're
not they're
they're using uh viral um
proteins rather than um the uh mrna
which is
basically just giving uh into the muscle
a message to make spike protein that's
modified
instead of the virus so it's perfect
because you don't have to risk
any virus it's just that one component
which is
an excellent target and by the way david
all the vaccines do have that common
thread
they use the spiked protein uh as the
primary target
is there anything what is import i'll
say it more broadly what is important
for the average vaccine recipient to
know
in terms of the differences for them
in receiving an mrna-based vaccine
versus the weakened or dead virus-based
vaccine
right so you know basically you have uh
two trials that came out first that were
very large you know forty four thousand
with the pfizer biontech and
thirty thousand plus with the moderna
they both had ninety five percent
efficacy
they both had really good safety profile
without uh concerns there
at least out to two months and that
should cover most of the
uh concerns on safety so that's kind of
the new reference standard
for the other vaccines so the
astrazeneca at the main dose that it's
been tested so far had an efficacy of 62
using a viral vector um and then others
have come in
at you know variable levels but they
haven't had as large
trial experience so what you really want
as a as a
vaccine knee a person getting a vaccine
you want to know how high is the
efficacy how well was it tested was it
in really large trials with good
follow-up these are important concerns
because
we're seeing some reduction in threshold
for getting approval because
obviously we're in a very dire situation
right now yeah
when we hear about numbers like 95
as you are talking about um that would
suggest
that out of every 20 people that get the
vaccine one will not develop
sufficient uh protection against
an infection is it possible to know
through an antibody test whether you are
in that five percent and if so
would it be potentially uh something you
could do
in in looking at getting an another
vaccine if you get the moderna and
you're in the five percent
can you go and get the pfizer and maybe
you'll be in the 19 out of 20 right
right that's a really great question um
and actually i share your uh interest in
having a neutralization antibody test
we don't have one that would tell you
for sure that you're protected
yeah because it isn't a hundred percent
in the modern
trial which was interesting for severe
infections that would require
hospitalization
it was 30 versus zero so it looked like
it was a hundred percent but those are
very small numbers yeah
um but so one thing is you want to be
protected
and and there's not it's not yes or no i
mean you want to be protected from
most importantly is severe infections
but you want to be fully protected
there's another layer of concern here
that isn't settled
and that is you could get the virus in
your upper airway particularly your
your nose nasal lining mucosa
and you could pass it on without
that this is that term of mucosal
immunity or
sterilization immunity and so we don't
have a full
readout on that yet we have some
encouraging preliminary data
so yes you're right if we could find out
the people who didn't get
the ideal response you could try another
vaccine
that's right and we don't have any you
know commercial assay to get
the answer to your question david we i
wish we did because
then you would about two weeks or a
month
after you got your second dose right you
would get a checkpoint
and then if you weren't um
high levels of neutralization antibiotic
you would get another vaccine that would
be the ideal scenario
but nobody's talking about that you're
you're the first one
that's really brought that out yeah and
you when you start doing the math if you
say well what what are the odds that
if you've got a room of people uh i mean
i think if i understand the math
correctly
if you have a room of 20 people and you
vaccinate all of them
uh there's a five percent chance one has
no immunity
and it is it correct to say there's a
two and a half percent chance
that two of those 20 end up with no
immunity i mean is the math that simple
well it's not quite that uh
precise the reason is is that you know
these trials were really large
and we're only talking about a tiny
subset right who were the first ones to
cross the line and get infections
so the numbers as you get much larger
could be different i mean this is kind
of giving you a ballpark there were
highly significant differences of course
yeah but it could turn out to be three
percent or
seven percent you know we we don't know
okay there's another part of this story
that's
interesting to point out and that is
this the trials are the ideal experience
that is they're conducted you know
rigorously with how the vaccines are
given
but in the real world they may gotten
thawed out early
you know they may not have you know been
cared for the
the actual uh sterile the uh the
the uh glass uh violence
vials yeah thank you uh
you know that we're not kept in the deep
freeze or whatever so you see
it it may be a little different in the
real world uh
it usually isn't better it's usually a
little worse right
so in terms of uh i mean i'll be very
transparent i think the logistical
rollout so far has been pretty
disastrous there were promises of 100
million doses in 2020
then promises of 20 million vaccinated
today as we talk we have about four and
a half million
first doses that have been given out
with question marks around how much if
any immunity you get from from the first
dose it seems
it's probably some but but we don't
really know and the vaccine makers are
being careful to say
it's not been tested at what level
do you believe we are going to start to
see
and you can answer either or both deaths
and or
cases noticeably pulled down by
vaccination
right well it has been uh a terrible
shortfall so far as you as you
aptly point out david uh we were
expecting at least 20 million people to
have
had their first dose in december right
and we're not even at quite at five
million yet so
there there is an issue of course that
their vaccines have largely been
delivered
that is there's close to 20 million out
there now but they're just not getting
in people's arms
shots now to get this herd immunity
which is the only way to get to
uh herd immunity not through natural
infections through vaccines
we need to get you know at least
approximately 70 percent of people but
the good part in the united states
if there is a good thing here is that we
let this virus
go with rampant spread and so we have at
least 60 to 70 million people who have
natural infection induced immune
response
so you believe that's important now so
that's about 3x the official cases you
believe the real infection rate is about
three times the official 20 million or
so that's right it was just published
today actually just before we got
together
in jama network open that uh it's at
least 3.2 x
of the numbers so we have 20 million so
we're about 65 million based on all the
the studies so the point here is that
we could get there faster go back to
your really great question about what if
we had a neutralization antibody to
the virus to the spike protein
uh if we had that and we could say
rapidly you
you have you're coming into your vaccine
you're you're in the line in the queue
and we tested you and a couple minutes
later you said well you're good to go
you're you're good right now you don't
need the vaccine we need to defer
you until we get to 70
now if we could tap into that 60 plus 65
million people we can get there a lot
faster
but if we don't do that we're looking at
you know
uh third quarter at best that means we
got to get to two to three million
vaccine uh people a day a day right plus
getting them all a second dose now
the j j vaccine which is the jansen's
coming out uh you know perhaps
early february even later this month if
that clicks that's a single dose so that
will make life easier plus it doesn't
require freezing
that will make logistics easier and it
will also add to our vaccine supply
but overall we're not going to get to
population immunity
that we need the faster the better
especially with this new
strain this new b117
we got to go fast now this is a race
against a
very challenging formidable
highly infectious variant one last
question about
the 60 million that we believe have have
been infected already
my understanding is there's still a
question as to the the duration and
robustness of the immunity
for recovered patients and questions
about for example
if you had a really mild case is how
does your
degree of immunity compare to someone
who recovered from a more severe case
does it last three months six months
nine i correct me if i'm wrong
if if reinfection was really common we
would have
way more examples of it if the number is
60 million that seems clear
but what do we know about the duration
of natural immunity
yeah oh you're really on this this is
great so
um the reinfection story uh you know in
the world
we have like 35 documented cases okay by
genomics that you you sequence the virus
in the first infection second they're
very different
we know that it was a reinfection
there's probably considerably more than
that but if you think about the world
number of infections it's really low
now that be speaks the issue that
natural immune response to an infection
is
quite good okay so the interesting thing
is the vaccine is what we've written
about
as superhuman that is it's even better
and what i what i mean by that is the
average person
now that we've looked out long enough
has at least eight or nine
months of protection at least okay maybe
even years but at least eight or nine
months
now remember you pointed out five
percent of people with a vaccine don't
have an ideal response about
let's say with the natural response it's
more than that
it could be 10 could be 12 you know it's
it's it's more because a vaccine gets a
much higher level of these neutralizing
antibodies which is the precious
response that drives your protection
uh no less you know t cells and and
other you know response that's part of
the
protection but most of it's the
neutralizing antibodies
so to answer your question you know i
think what we're what we
can say is if you have a neutralizing
antibody
if it's still there at good levels
you're you're good to be deferred i mean
you know you don't need a vaccine right
now
we need that for other people to get us
to this
because we we are unfortunately going to
face a vaccine shortage
uh unlike israel which is the lead you
know the pacesetter they're gonna have
enough vaccines they order early they
have
a supply they have enough vaccines for
everybody yeah i believe
i believe they're at 14 already yeah
actually that was
as of the third as of today they're
probably they're going at least one and
a half percent a day so
they're they're probably at least 16
percent they've they've now have
all the vaccines you know they need to
get everybody vaccinated
uh who's willing which is most people of
course there unlike what we have which
is
some hesitancy resistance anti-vaxxers
but even with our
our our issues our biggest problem is
getting
shots in the arm getting the second
doses
at high scale you know like we did it in
1947 with smallpox
when we had six and a half million
people in a few weeks
we've got to be doing that now every day
throughout the country
so give us a few bullet points there's
so much that could be said about the
logistics that could be organized but
give us a few bullet points about things
that should be done right away one
anecdotal story
my stepmom works in healthcare but not
as a direct provider she works for a
company that that
you know in sort of management i guess
you would say and she got
a call on january 1st saying listen we
got vaccines
for the first responders we have two
vaccines left over
there's no system for us to send these
to a
for nurses at a different place we just
have two vaccines
and they're gonna go bad do you want a
vaccine and she said sure
that multiplied by a hundred million it
it seems uninconceivably chaotic so like
what are the logistical things that need
to happen here
right well you know it is uh crazy that
we're not
just trying to do everything we can to
get vaccines into people
um and so we waste uh you know a lot of
shots
um obviously what you know once they're
they're thawed
if they don't get uh used they're
they're lost and we just don't want any
of that to happen so
we need mass events you know we need uh
an all-out um effort to get
you know a huge number of people every
day
throughout the country and that well
that's you know getting
uh stadiums uh and big facilities where
you know just people on an hourly basis
show up and quick you know get their
jab or whether it's mobile uh you know
uh efforts you know with with vans and
you know
whatever it takes obviously pharmacies
could help here
you know because they're pretty widely
distributed so the walgreens and cvs
they should be part of the story as well
but we need you know this idea that um
you know i have
high regard for the new administration
but they're talking about 100 million
vaccines in a hundred days well that's
only 50 million people in the 100 days
of the
new administration that's not neat yeah
it sounds so good
and yet the math of it is still falling
very short
absolutely yeah so that's just not going
to work we have to be a whole lot more
aggressive
and i hope that's going to change i i
hope so
we've been speaking with dr eric topel
who is founder
and director of the scripps research
translational institute also a professor
of molecular medicine
um dr toppo such a pleasure having you
and i really appreciate your time i know
you're very busy
well i'm really impressed how well
you're on this david uh you you've
really
uh i didn't think you had a science
background but it sure looks like it
i don't my my formal training is in
business if you could imagine
no but i mean listen this is the it's
the issue of our time you know and uh
for my audience's sake i must remain
informed
well you're a fast learner great to meet
you and great to have a conversation
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpackman.com
that's
join pakman.com
if the normal prices strike you as high
by all means
use the coupon code vote soon 18 all one
word
all lower case become a member today
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so yesterday we played clips for you of
this absolutely ridiculous phone call
that donald trump made to the georgia
secretary of state
asking them to find 11 780 votes and
then saying come on guys i just need 11
000 votes to win georgia
um and certainly that call is
impeachable donald trump should be
impeached for that he's not going to be
i don't think
anyway he could be impeached after
leaving office but it doesn't seem that
there is a
political desire for impeachment but one
of the very
interesting things that has come out of
it is that georgia secretary of state
brad raffensberger who was on that call
he was the one being pressured and he is
a republican
being pressured to find a way to give
donald trump the state of georgia
he said it's unlikely we would
investigate
uh or or uh investigate criminally or
ask criminal charges to be brought
because we have a conflict of interest
we were involved in the call but it is
certainly something
criminal investigation and possibly even
charges that
an atlanta area district attorney could
do and this is once again
it's just the tip of the iceberg of what
we may see once donald trump is out of
office
and of course this should be
investigated here is the georgia
secretary of state
republican brad raffensberger explaining
since he's involved in this he really
shouldn't be part of the investigation
and he's right about that
but says that there are others including
the atlanta area district attorney
uh that might be the right outfit to
investigate
david warley a democratic member of the
state election board which you chair has
asked you to open an investigation
into the call will you open that
investigation
i believe that because i had a
conversation with the president
also he had a conversation with our
chief investigator after we did the
signature match audit
of cobb county last week there may be a
conflict of interest i understand that
the fulton county district attorney
wants to look at it
maybe that's the appropriate venue for
it to go so the the first question and
we'll go through this sequentially the
first question is what crimes
might trump have committed here and it's
actually a long list
and i'm not saying trump will face
charges i'm saying the list of possible
crimes
is long federal laws against
solicitation of election fraud
i would argue were broken to prove it
you need to know intent
um but and and that is hard to prove but
just because something can't be proven
in court doesn't mean that colloquially
speaking you and i can't say yeah trump
did that
federal laws against conspiracy to
intimidate threaten
injure or oppress any person of rights
secured by the constitution georgia
state law against solicitation of
election fraud arguably was broken
and georgia state law against willfully
tampering with an elector list
voter certificate ballot box voting
machine
tabulating equipment or to solicit
others
to commit such tampering so as i told
you before
with other trump investigations i don't
think this is going to go very far
but it may be yet another thorn in
trump's side once he leaves office
i think the most realistic scenario is
not trump ever gets perp walked in
handcuffs
not trump is even never criminally
charged with anything i think the most
likely scenario if i'm being just
you know not hyperbolic but but but sort
of conservative in my thinking with you
is there will be investigations into
trump
and his organization that will be a
thorn
in trump's side for years to come
now another interesting aspect of this
why was the call recorded to begin with
we know now that the georgia officials
on the call did the recording and they
did it because of their knowledge that
donald trump
previously has lied about the content of
phone calls
so the recording was almost like an
insurance policy for them
assuming trump would later lie about
what was said they wanted a record to be
able to say
here's what was actually said so it's
all completely embarrassing and
you know if only we could have seen this
coming right like if back in 2016
when when we were all sounding the alarm
and unfortunately there were some on the
left and right who were saying
it won't be that bad trump for four
years might even get us a true
progressive in 2020 that we would all be
happy with trump will shake things up
he'll sort of bring
a different approach it has certainly
been different
there's no doubt about that but it has
been an
absolute and complete disaster regularly
attacking in authoritarian
fashion uh multiple endless aspects
of our democratic systems and
undoubtedly trump should be
impeached after the fact for this
there's no question whatsoever on the
merits
whether he will or won't be i don't know
is it even worth doing
i mean listen as i said before there is
a duty to impeach
if you believe an impeachable action has
taken place
uh and we sort of have to separate the
potential outcome
which is not going to be very much uh
from from the duty to do what is right
as
uh as congress is supposed to do but i i
at this point we're at a loss and it's
simply an emergency to get rid of this
guy we're down to 15 days
we are down to the last 15 days
different people handle loss differently
there are sore losers there are angry
losers
there are depressive losers there are
narcissists who tend to go more in the
direction of i didn't want to win anyway
there's a really broad range of reaction
to loss and it often changes over time
we're seeing something really
interesting on fox news which is that
suddenly they are all about
their feelings and the feelings of
conservatives
and the feelings of trumpists how
everybody
feels about the election numbers how
everybody
feels about the election results how
some of their feelings are now
hurt by what has taken place and you've
got to see some of these examples
here is one from fox and friends
yesterday morning
where ainsley earhart one of the hosts
says you know
staunch conservatives they feel the
defeated they has a sad for lack of a
better term take a listen
well i think people who are staunch
conservatives in our country just feel
so
just so defeated because of this
election they do feel like it was rigged
and then to see what's happening in
georgia
that the democrats could have the house
democrats could have the senate
and the presidency and that's the that's
the danger
did you hear that it's disheartening
for staunch conservatives that they lost
where was this understanding back in
2008
where was this understanding back in
2012 i don't recall it from these same
people
now part of the irony of all this is
that the right has this idea of the
facts don't care about your feelings
that's a meme
that they love pushing on to the left
and now
they all need time and we need to be
careful with their feelings because they
are fragile and and and disheartened by
what they are seeing
here's another while by the way
advocating for the
uh um essentially for the setting aside
of the actual results because they just
feel
bad about it here's another one from
yesterday on fox
this is senator ron johnson who says
we can't just ignore the concerns
and suspicions from right wingers
i i guess because there are concerns and
suspicions what we hold up joe biden's
inauguration
check this out absent proof absent
evidence
republican senator ron johnson says we
can't just dismiss the concerns of
people here
from my standpoint we simply cannot
dismiss
the concerns of tens of millions of
americans that have have
suspicions wow we've got to be careful
guys
the suspicions and concerns of these
americans
who have fallen for donald trump's bogus
claims about voter fraud
they need to be babied because they feel
bad
and they want to put aside the results
of the election it's just
absolutely wacky and here's the cherry
on top in this last clip
this is from the same episode of fox and
friends that we looked at uh in the
first clip
fox reporter griff jenkins is in dalton
georgia that's the location of last
night's trump rally
and there's apparently a fan of fox
anchor ainsley earhardt
at the rally and the fan rushes over and
every detail of this exchange is bonkers
now of course neither the reporter nor
the trumpist are wearing masks
the guy actually has a shirt on that
says the only thing worse than kovid 19
would be biden 20 and he's hugging griff
jenkins
and you can actually hear steve ducey in
the fox studio he sounds uncomfortable
about what's going on
this is just out of this world i was
going to say go give terry from detroit
our fan
a big hug but we can't do that right
terry
you cannot hug him you can't just he
said
to say two seconds on my microphone what
do you want to say to ainsley
we love you ainsley oh terry i love you
terry i want to talk to you you came
from detroit god bless america and god
bless the president
she loves you too and she can't believe
you came from detroit why do you come
from detroit
because i love the president we want to
back him 100 percent all right thank you
jerry
look at that t-shirt what does it say
terry what's your t-shirt say the only
thing worse than covet 19 would be biden
20. what's up and that's the truth
thank you so much guys god bless you
terry thank you thank you griff
we love trump all right writing this
team back to you all right let's bring
it
they're doing this stuff with smiles on
their faces if you can
imagine that it is another country out
there
holy covid my friends is my only
reaction
uh what are these people going to do
when when when uh
former vice president and now
president-elect joe biden is sworn in
i there are some who say it's going to
be violence others say
it will be dejection and evaporation
into the ether
i don't know the answer but it's
certainly scary we have a voicemail
number and that number
is 2192 david p here's something i've
actually heard from a bunch of people
about mask wearing listen to this
hey david so everybody who works in my
office takes the
coronavirus pandemic seriously uh when
they're outside the office
but then once we get inside they all
take their masks off
they're not worried about social
distancing or anything like that
and i'm the only one who keeps my mask
on keeps hand sanitizing
you know um how bad do you think
that this false sense of safety is
contributed
to the chronovirus spread hugely and i
i've heard from this from other people
i'm really good with my mask it's mostly
red states i'm pretty sure that in blue
states every every place says you've got
to have a mask on uh
at a place of work indoors it's a
generalization blue and red states but
i've heard from people who who work in
arkansas for example south carolina
south carolina is another example
that uh begrudgingly you know outdoors
um people will wear masks they'll wear
them at the grocery store etc
but but then at their place of work they
take them off and
even if you work with only eight people
and each of those eight people
is only interacting at home with two
others you're still exposed to
dozens of people's contacts and i know
of many people who have gotten
sick this way and again most of the
contagion is happening within homes
and at places of work particularly
indoor places of work so i don't really
get it
to me the outdoor is less of a priority
i'm still doing it because i'm a team
player but
the indoor particularly when you're at
work all day with people when we know
the longer you're around people
the more likely a contagion event is to
take place
i really don't get it at this point i'm
sort of beyond
trying to understand the logic that
folks are applying
to when they do and don't wear masks i i
i'm sort of at a loss but i've heard
that from many people
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about the potential
extradition of julian assange we will
talk about jack ma and other chinese
billionaires
mia after criticizing the chinese
government and
much much more get instant access to
today's bonus show
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman
steadymd lets you maintain a meaningful
long-lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with any time over
phone or video chat you don't need
insurance it's only 99
a month with no other fees or co-pays
visit
steadymd.com pacman to get started